alright so let's take a look at this
monster of a function once again we
start off by defining whether or not
this is a static or dynamic object and
of course setting the proper flag to the
body definition type so the first thing
we do is we actually start off by
defining whether or not this is a static
or dynamic body and assign a particular
flag to the type property of the body
definition next since the calling
function probably has information about
where they want this object to be
spawned we go ahead and set the position
X and position Y value so the physics
object can actually exist in the world
in the correct place from there we call
our register body function which will of
course invoke box2d to create a physics
object and return to us a handle or
representation of it and then we go
through with creating a fixture
definition now the defaults for a
fixture definition object are generally
pretty good and that's what we use for
most objects and grits however for the
bouncy fixture we actually changed the
density friction and restitution so that
when an object hits a wall it will
contain a lot of its velocity moving
away this means that bouncy bullets
maintain a high velocity and ability to
kill other players since they don't lose
any energy in impacts with walls finally
what we'll do is actually create a shape
object with a new polygon shape as
standard API calling defines and then
we'll call set as box passing in half
width and half height from there we call
the create fixture objects which
attaches this definition to the body
object and return it out to the calling
class and if you got all that then you
deserve a cookie